the attention graph is all I care about  where is the attention of the consumer  where are they spending their time  snapchat to me right now March 2015 is  slightly below Instagram in the overall  game but when you're talking 13 to 23 it  is number one by the way I wanted to  echo here it is number one in attention  and so I'm a big big fan of snapchat  it's mobile first the mobile device is  the king and queen of the game and the  video product in it is quite unique  because this is one of the places where  you can actually do creative on top of  the raw video function so not only am i  producing video but then on top of that  can I draw a little funny pictures on  top of myself can I like animate on top  of it that is a very huge creative  output so the attention of 13 to 25 and  the ability to be creative on top of the  video make it very unique  there is no drawing on top of any other  video on any other planet